are we watching a bromance unfold in
real time or was there something else
going on between Pedro Pascal and Kieran
cin here's why Pascal was slinging shade
at Ken at the Emmys the viewers of the
75th prime time Emmy Awards may have
done a double take when Pedro Pascal
showed up with his arm in a sling but
they did a triple take when he called
out Kieran cin completely out of the
blue Pascal took to the podium to
present an award and opened by saying
before we get into the nominees for best
supporting actor in a drama series I'd
like to take just a second to make this
about me a lot of people have been
asking about my arm the broadcast
censored the punch line of his story but
the uncensored clip on YouTube clarified
what he said Pascal continued it's
actually my shoulder and I think this is
a perfect time to tell everyone that
Kieran ckin beat the without me
immediately after the cameras treated
viewers to a closeup of a stone-faced
coin staring at Pascal audiences got a
laugh and a few seconds later coin
cracked a smile as well award shows are
full of friendly Jabs between actors but
still what was that all about first of
all no coin didn't really beat up Pascal
at least probably not on January 7th the
actor told reporters that had had
accidentally Fallen his emy's joke
played out more like a bit of joking
Revenge at the 2024 Golden Globes Pascal
and coim were both nominated for the
Golden Globe for best performance by an
actor in a drama series for their work
on the Last of Us and succession coin W
and took a jab of his own at Pascal in
his acceptance speech he said thanks to
session I've been in here a couple times
it's nice but I sort of accepted I was
never going to be on the stage so this
is a nice moment suck it Pedro even this
wasn't the beginning of the friendly
sniping between the pair it's merely the
latest chapter in what shaping up to be
an endearing Bromance between two of the
hottest actors in Hollywood in 2023 the
actors sat side by side during the
Hollywood reporters Roundtable
discussion along with Jeff Bridges Evan
Peters Michael Imperioli and damson
Idris throughout he and Pascal
demonstrated an easy chemistry that at
times resembled a seasoned comedy act
amazingly gave me the opportunity to be
able to go and and do something else
that's good do you ever feel that that
like like I have a question it looks
like the two have decided to continue
the fun and gains throughout the awards
season though Pascal once again lost out
to Kim when they were up for the same
award at the Emmys cameras captured the
two meeting up in a crowd at the
Afterparty well they appeared to be on
perfectly good terms laughing and
smiling for the cameras one video posted
to X showed in reaching up to Pat Pascal
on the right shoulder his injured one
leading Pascal to not so subtly move the
hand to his good shoulder fans have been
loving the dynamic between Pascal and
kin the whole time after Pascal's joke
at the Emmys fans took to social media
to share their love for the Duos Dynamic
one person Rose the real Winner Is Us
witnessing the evolution of the duo that
is Pedro Pascal and Kieran cin meanwhile
another person compared their Dynamic to
some other fan favorite celebrity
friendships writing Kieran Coan and ad
Pascal are the new Ryan Reynolds and
Hugh Jackman The Rock and Kevin Hart Ken
Jung and Joel mcale another user
expressed hope that the decision makers
in Hollywood were taking notes of the
obvious Chemistry Between Pascal and
culen finally one user had just a single
humble request writing I wish every
award season could include Kieran Culkin
and Pedro Pascal whether they're winning
trophies or just razing each other on
stage we too would like to see more of
Pedro Pascal and kieren kkin antic a
future award show
see